even though
things seem to be resolving very well in
ottawa this state of emergency is not
over
justin trudeau is not done going after
the canadian truckers even though the
police broke up the convoy and arrested
nearly 200 protesters this weekend
ottawa's police chief says they will
track down and punish anyone who is
involved in a protest
if you are involved in this protest we
will actively look to identify you and
follow up with financial sanctions and
criminal charges absolutely
this investigation will go on for months
to come
and truckers who have not been arrested
are dealing with the fallout of frozen
bank accounts and seized assets they've
uh they've taken my truck i don't know
where it is on friday they locked up my
personal and
trucking business accounts and also we
have another business and they locked
that account up too and it had nothing
to do with it
yeah just going to take everything from
you because you uh you spoke up right
dana you know a little bit about i don't
know handling a crisis
communications happens you could write a
book of how not to handle a crisis and
justin trudeau would be like on the
cover this um but what really bothers me
about it is the the gentleman you just
saw that was interviewed by bill this
morning so he has a separate business
that has nothing to do with the protest
and they seize those bank accounts as
well so he can't make any sort of living
i think it's outrageous for them to say
that they're going to track people down
for months they left they're no longer
there the crisis
so to speak is over i also wonder about
where are the pro bono lawyers to try to
help challenge these uh accounts being
seized because to me i i don't know
canadian law but i would assume maybe
emily could say like there has to be
some way to push back against that i
think about all those celebrities who
say they're going to move to canada and
every time a republican president is
elected i assume that they're probably
glad that they live in a country where
their property can't be seized because
they sent a donation to the truckers
jesse we're talking about seizing bank
accounts and assets this one guy said
they seized
assets of a business that has nothing to
do with his trucking business this is
retaliation how would that settle in
this country like what what would we do
as americans if the government came
after us uh for exercising i don't know
our second amendment right
well that's why we have a second
amendment joby jones exactly we must
send peacekeeping forces to canada at
this point that's our only recourse
you know unfortunately canada has a lot
of british dna in them they never
rebelled against the monarchy like we
did here in america so i think they're
more accustomed to king-like rule and i
only say this having been to canada
twice but i looked into their legal
system and it's not anything like the
freedom we have here they they don't
take religious liberty as seriously as
we do their gun control laws are
hyper-strict you can't even leave your
house with a handgun in canada um you
know that the government runs the health
care system over there and hate
speech is a crime so when we think of
things happening in canada it's not just
like some
colder version of america just to the
north i mean this is a radically
different legal system so we're shocked
when they seize that colder
know in america you see that i said in
america it's because you forged some
checks or your you know your back taxes
haven't cleared with the irs
you donated to a peaceful protest that
that would happen anywhere in the in in
the northern hemisphere is crazy so if
america wants to be respected as
a beacon of liberty geraldo a shining
city on hill when communist countries do
this when dictators do things like this
freeze assets go door to door put people
in prison for peaceful protest we speak
up and we should speak up and the fact
that you're doing
that right up there geraldo we should be
screaming you have been speaking up and
i want to know if you're going to stick
with these truckers now that they need
you for their legal defense you're
egging them on along with other
conservative comments
i'm standing on principle i would seize
assets
i was arrested after uh passing the bar
taking the bar july 1969 is in
washington d.c in the protest
i was going to be admitted to bar in
november i was totally delayed because
of my protest participation you have to
understand there's consequences when you
shut down
shut down a country as they did in
canada so so you're saying that that
free speech although it exists in a
different way there should result in
being trampled by a horse and having
your livelihood towed i don't want to
get into horse trampling again we're
getting to the border patrol and all
that uh you know one
it's not about horses and trampling it's
about shutting down canada for three and
a half weeks
they the people of ottawa were totally
inconvenienced they had trucks running
all night long the horns blowing they
had people be making they wore masks
they were being made fun of by the
protesters you paint them in this
picture like they're you know it's it's
robin hood
wait wait you're saying the protesters
made fun of someone
they harassed people oh my god
imagine if you put them in prison if you
had a mask on look at that [ __ ] look at
that oh my god
emily i guess it's a good thing we have
the first amendment in this country
because i remember not that long ago
there were protests that that we would
go on this channel and say hey we
support that protest but when it turns
into a riot then we feel like the police
should come in you know what they didn't
come in and they burned federal
buildings down and it got really ugly
really quick that hasn't happened up
there but instead most of them left and
the ones that didn't get arrested but
they're still according to the police
chief going to hunt you down and bring
consequences that's vindictive is it not
yeah so well i just want to respond to
what you said so the reason that your
your bar
license was yeah you wasn't you um was
held up you know you you only your
license is suspended terminated or not
instated if it's a crime of moral
turpitude and and protesting under
protected free speech is not that when
you talk about the inconvenience
canadians suffered at the hands of these
peaceful protesters that pales in
comparison with having a voice and you
do that little violin geraldo but this
is people's livelihoods these are
people's convictions what about the
livelihoods of the auto workers who
didn't get the parts so they couldn't
put together their fords and their
toyotas because these people closed the
bridge again that's a minor yeah one of
those is my best friend and he would
call you right now and tell you he also
doesn't want a government telling him he
should get a vaccine or vaccinate his
kids and that's part of the that's part
of this problem here that's the rest of
this conversation it's not just the
inconvenience of the people that live in
ottawa or perhaps washington dc
yeah and just as a quick final point you
know the supreme court here obviously
has ensured that political donations are
protected by free speech canada
obviously doesn't have that same
protection as we know uh but there's a
big argument here that financial deep
platforming is the next step of this
online censorship that we've experienced
sort of by social media by those bit by
paypal and whatnot sort of identifying
well we're going to take this person off
we're going to deny them but this what
we are seeing the magnitude and the
ripple effect of these people's
livelihoods being absolutely um
catastrophically
expunged i know we have to go um that's
something that we need to keep on and
and if the pen relinquishment thing
actually happens there is a special
place in the endless embers for that
government hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else